the Cold War finished more than three
decades ago many Americans thought it
also brought an end to the spy games
that defined that era but a new book
shows the spies were there all along
living among us
it says Russian spying on Moscow's
perceived enemies in the West never
really ended instead it is just evolved
and intensified Russians among us
sleeper cells ghost stories and the hunt
for Putin spies covers the espionage
conducted by Russia and the United
States since the 1990s through the 2016
election author gordon carrera is also
security correspondent at our partners
the BBC gordon good morning this is a
fascinating book because it basically
says we took our eye off the ball
absolutely while Russia was patiently
and aggressively spying on the West the
West thought the Cold War was over there
was no need to worry about this and I
really start the book in 2010 when there
was this bust by the FBI of a group of
Russian Deep Cover spies called illegals
and it was seen as a kind of weird
throwback a joke when they were swapped
for some other Russians in jail people
didn't take it seriously but actually it
was a sign that Russia had not given up
its method some of which came from the
Cold War but some of which were new and
evolving but let's talk about those deep
those illegals in Deep Cover because
when one of them was a restaurant name
was Cindy Cindy Murphy's Richard and
Cindy Murphy were American names they
said it can't be Cindy she likes to
guard and look at her hydrangeas I mean
they were doing normal everyday stuff
which was so fascinating today that's
right they were living in the suburbs
she was doing taxes for people yes she
and the others had those spent years
decades building their cover as
Americans posing as Americans when they
were in fact Russians they've learned to
live to sleep to dream in another
language to hide every aspect of their
Russian part they would have children
they had ill Janeane and what about that
when they were arrested
I remember one one scene that stood out
to me the FBI knew the kids nicknames
they knew the code to the garages and
the kids are like our parents are spies
yeah I mean so the FBI I've been
watching this group for years they knew
they were Russian spies but the children
of these spots is not what they were
Americans they thought they were
Americans and then one day the FBI is in
the
and they're told nope you're Russians
and your parents are spies the FBI broke
this case because they had a critical
informant inside the upper levels of
Russian intelligence that's right that's
one of the things I go into detail of
that new detail in the book is about
this agent called Alexander pitaya who
was recruited here in New York in 1999
by the FBI and then run jointly with the
CIA in Moscow for a decade and it was
the fact when he became nervous that the
Russians might be on to him he felt he
had to get out in 2010 and then that war
this whole operation to a close well he
is in hiding because absolutely there is
a risk to his life I mean one of the
people swapped in 2010 for these
illegals was a man codes called Sergei
script are gated for assassination with
nerve agent in Britain two years ago
that gives you some idea how seriously
Putin took this episode curious that
these illegals were outed he I was told
he was so furiously his papers up in the
air when he found out they'd been
arrested he was so angry because it cut
to his identity
he's a former KGB officer he sees
himself as a master spy who'd put an end
to Russia's humiliation and then
suddenly here are his spies the spies
he's so proud of being arrested and
shown up and so that was a really
important moment in changing the way
Putin saw his relationship with the way
we've seen the Russians attack people in
England former agents do you think
they'd ever do it here well I've spoken
to US intelligence officials who
certainly think it's possible a few
years ago they thought it would never
happen the Russians wouldn't risk it now
some even say what we're preparing for
that day we're not if it happens they've
seen Russia become more aggressive more
brazen more willing to take risks than
it was in the past using new methods
cyber illegals who create false
identities in days online but also
willing to use violence in a way they
weren't really willing to use in the
past Gordon what's the endgame here for
Putin and Russia I think he wants to
hold on to power and he believes that he
wants to keep the West off balance and
he's using his spies to basically divide
us to keep us off balance to give
himself more room for no maneuver and to
keep his hold on power in Russia
that's essentially what motivates people
to turn on their own country though
Gordon that's a good question I think
it's different it's a really complicated
one I mean of course sometimes it's
money sometimes it's an ideology
something
it's just a sense of grievance it's
really complicated and talking to spies
and you just get a sent it to a very
human individual story that's what I
wanted to capture in the book sometimes
is about it's about the human stories
about why people get involved in spying
and what it's like and what it's like to
have a family and be a spy you did it
very well
Gordon Carrera thank you so much
Russians among us is on sale today